he was born in the Soviet Union and came
to the US when he was three years old as
a kid he earned thousands of dollars on
weekends trading baseball cards today he
runs vaynermedia and is one of the most
sought-after public speakers alive he's
Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 20 enjoy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one have thick skin I got very
lucky I grew up in a situation where I
was losing from day one we were humble
immigrants I got picked on for not
speaking English I wasn't a good student
I wasn't then excelling athlete which
allowed me to create an enormous amount
of thick skin to doing things and not
being scared of judgment because I was
being judged from the beginning do you
does not noxious ly think my skin is
when it comes to business not give what
anybody says about me or thinks of me or
thinks what I'm doing I'm willing to go
work picking up garbage right now right
now it just doesn't seem so crazy to me
people get fancy I'm still doing the
[ __ ] that got me here even though people
think I got somewhere you may think I
got somewhere I don't think I'm
somewhere I'm still in the same process
rule number two live your hobby this is
my first time filming really
I love doing this like I've said it over
and over you can probably clip 13
different kinds of sin in the last month
like this is my hobby yeah this is my
passions what I'd love to do I love
building businesses this is fun for me
like I'd rather be doing this than
playing for night I'd rather be doing
this than skiing I'd rather be doing
this in rock climbing yoga cooking
watching Game of Thrones this is my
hobby most people don't do their hobby
as their profession like I just don't
think most people are living their hobby
rule number three be practical
my dad is a 100% default cynic my mom is
a 100% optimist and I understand it both
so I look at everything through both of
their eyes and so I understand so I you
know I have I I'm to be honest I'm I'm
grateful that I skewed more towards
optimism it's what entrepreneurship
needs you're blindly optimistic like you
can't do this an entrepreneur does
unless you're delusional and optimistic
right but b-but I was so grateful that I
got into my dad's sphere of cynicism
right because what it did was it allowed
me not to become delusional there was a
level of practicality then over later
did I think practicality is amazing I
think I'm I'm crazy practical it's why
for 25 years I've built businesses never
borrowed money never lost money or like
I'm always practical so and I think
that's a kissing cousin sometimes the
cynicism and I think you know I have a
friend who's like I'm cynical like
you're practical
you've got a little hint of cynicism and
I think you know those you know I'm
optimistic but I'm not delusional
rule number four go all-in what was the
hardest lesson for you to learn with
regard to putting up content like
whether were something's were doing
or something that you weren't that you
should have been that's a great question
you know what's funny it's back to kind
of how I answer that question I'm so not
good at thinking about like the
negatives of things like it's hard for
me to even recall I first of all was
very early right I I was one of the
first people on YouTube when the first
people on Twitter so I learned whatever
like I think but you know actually I got
one I've been so write so consistently
that a lot of who I am right now in this
room telling people to push the biggest
lesson I had to learn is I kept being so
right but I didn't squeeze every ounce
add a bit when I was right to you I
don't play poker but to use the analogy
I would consistently have nuts have the
best hand but I wasn't going all-in
right like my great business regret is I
was right about Google AdWords I ran
Google AdWords the day Google AdWords
stuff started the day and it was one of
the biggest arbitrage as ever
right and I took my dad's business from
3 to 60 and everybody gives me dabs for
that but always in my mind you know when
sometimes happen and he took his
family's you know when I'm getting
announced in at stage every time I'm
like should have been 250 because I
should have went harder and I've been
saying it now for 3 years and a lot of
people here who follow me will tell you
now that the Facebook arbitrage is not
as good now that they're starting to see
the Instagram if you've been paying
attention Instagram last month it feels
like it started that you're not getting
as many likes and views as you did like
I keep telling people like this goes
away it's like but you know I don't know
how long people in real estate like you
find a new neighborhood that was stuff
but then it gets gender fide and you
bought one house you know I should have
what 7 so the one lesson that I've up
with and I canti me to try to get better
at is when I've got it I squeeze the got
it in if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below
we are sluggish we're really strong
we're just being sold that we're not
because there's a lot of money the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
in a success world please understand
that success is happy
not net dollars in rule number five be
brutally honest hey I think we have to
stop giving seventh place trophies it's
bad for kids I told my son the other day
my son is all about sports now I told
him right to his beautiful little face
the other day I'm like he said to me dad
how old am I gonna be when I can dunk I
said bro you're never gonna dunk he said
why I said genetics but tennis is great
and it might be something you know or he
might buy a basketball team but but
what's really fun and this is now me
going through it right hypotheses are
cute executions different listening to
him three weeks later play with one of
his friends and he's telling his friend
to take jump shots like he's like no no
let's go out here and take shots he goes
and and and he goes because we're never
gonna put it on him to that kid won't
donkey either but but he goes cuz we're
never gonna dunk and Nicky goes wide
goes because my dad told me and I just
keep playing it over in my mind me being
radically can Duras with him it's gonna
help him it's gonna help him be a human
that can deal with adversity and things
that don't come like like life and it's
gonna help him actually in something
he's passionate about because if he just
stays on the outside he could be a nice
little you know pickup basketball player
if he doesn't play around the rim like
every other idiot that never gets to
dunk and actually works on a jump shot I
don't know this is something we need to
bring back into society merit
accountability we need to put these on
pedestals not over coddling fake
environments rule number six
do what you want once you start living
your life based on what your parents
expectations are or anybody else's
you've begun the process of not being
that is just the truth who's happy doing
something that they don't want to be
doing
nobody you may be content you may deal
with it but you're not happy I'm really
passionate about that I've been I've
become outrageously passionate about
keeping up with the Joneses as we call
it in America like insecurities
it kills you just you start doing things
that you can't afford rule number seven
love the game I'm telling you with my
whole soul go meet anybody who has known
me for 40 years
I love losing I love it love it
I live for it here's why cuz I think I
deserve it if I play you one-on-one and
you be me like what I'm not like I love
the merit of the game
- I love entrepreneurship I like when my
companies fail or my strategies fail or
we lose a client I love it
I mean it I mean it I mean it I mean it
rule number eight put out content I'm
telling you right now this is the single
most important thing in our society when
it comes to business if you were not
putting out content on the Twitter
Facebook Instagram LinkedIn youtubes of
the world you are becoming vulnerable
and irrelevant over time most of you
don't put out enough content because
you're trying to think about what to say
just filming yourself on your hustle and
talking about your tree that's the
content you need to put out you have to
make content for the Internet the
content is the gateway drug to growth in
business in today's environment rule
number nine ignore this system
I hear start tracking I'm like okay I'm
gonna start a Star Trek podcast then I'm
gonna take 18 months it's gonna pop dead
I'm gonna be able to you know I'll do
something on the side but then I'll be
able to start like selling hoodies which
Star Trek like I think I can become an
entrepreneur I think I can get to a
hundred thousand on any an idea but I'm
talented and I'm an entrepreneur it's
okay if you're not an entrepreneur but
it still speaks to its truth it is
possible and me and like and if it's not
long-term like you didn't build it then
go get a job my thing is like you could
always get the job you could always
succumb
why are people starting by folding their
hand
[Music]
play because the system told you to
falter and because it put you in
detention if you were rowdy and
charismatic but I didn't listen to you
system I didn't listen to you system I
lived it because I didn't respect it
because I thought it was a facade and I
ended up being right and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun everyone want
vegetables overly empathy bros a and if
you had to air one soft cheese with
absolutely rose a empty rows a fish o
with fish empathy rose a like a chicken
yeah empathy rose a me maybe you stay
there empathy rose a alright a finally
if you did to spare with a dessert what
would it be like a coconut cream pie
that or maybe just like a sprinkle
cupcake the empathy rose a I was
fighting to stay alive the whole time
oh I think you should do a make a piece
of content that's like a spin the bottle
I'm gonna kiss one of you so get ready
the Iraq I know you've always wanted it
that was amazing now we're gonna stretch
a bone escape from Gary on how to be
self aware that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go
question number one what can you do to
have more fun in your business today
number two where do you need to just
ignore the system and number three what
content are you gonna put out this week
there is no correlation between how much
money someone makes and their level of
happiness I have friends who make forty
seven thousand dollars a year and are
the happiest people I know their
work-life balance is on point they're
part of two soccer teams they play video
games they watch every show they want
they take two vacations that they
scrapped
gather and they're freakin happy as hell
and I know tons of people who I grew up
with in the Silicon Valley boom who have
hundreds of millions of dollars in their
bank account and are is miserable and is
lonely and is broken as you'll ever see
so I implore all of you to please
reverse engineer and figure out who you
are and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need and what
level of creativity need I promise you
one thing one thing that will catch you
very off guard and I should be way more
rich I leave money on the table every
day i I've left
ungodly amounts of money on the table I
spend tons of times
spending sending DMS and engaging with
people meeting people randomly and not
cashing in I actually believe the
statement I'm about to make I think that
I love the journey and the game of
entrepreneurship so much that I have
subconsciously sabotage my financial
upside to make sure I can play this a
little longer because I fear if the
numbers keep getting too big eventually
it will take the fun out of it when you
were lucky enough like I am to actually
do something that you love so much do
something that puts pressure against the
one thing you care about besides it
which is the time I spend with my family
my family is my whole life and being
this and doing this is the only thing
that cuts into that I couldn't breathe
if I wasn't an entrepreneur I didn't
breathe when I wasn't an entrepreneur
that's the reason I got these in F's in
school
because I just couldn't be me and I'm
not capable of that but I want to remind
everybody just cuz he didn't grow up
with a trust fund just because you don't
live in Silicon Valley the market
doesn't care if you're good enough you
will win
if you want more garyvee check out the
top 50 rules video and wait on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and if you don't
adjust to the reality of the situation
you will be completely left behind too
many people are executing